[Music]
trench warfare the salem witch trials
doping scandals in sports they're all
completely unrelated events right well
it turns out that psychologists have
created a thought game and it helps to
explain the decisions that people have
made in these exact situations
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
experts share how the prisoner's dilemma
can apply to more than just criminal
behavior we start now with the rules of
the prisoner's dilemma and just how
complicated those rules become when
people's sense of self-preservation gets
involved enjoy
[Music]
the prisoner's dilemma is a situation in
which two people are given a choice of
whether to cooperate or defect
mutual cooperation will get the overall
best result but since individually
defection is in their best interest
they will defect and actually get the
worst possible result i know that may
seem a little confusing so let's
consider a particular case so
two prisoners are suspected of a crime
if they both keep quiet they will get
only one year in jail
if each squeals on the other they will
get four years each but if one squeals
and the other doesn't the squealer goes
free
and the other gets six years
notice that for each person it is better
to defect no matter what the other
person does say you're person a
if you think person b is going to squeal
then you should squeal two if person b
squeals and you don't you'll get six
years but if you squeal two you only get
four
but if you think he's going to cooperate
you should still squeal if you both
cooperate you'll still get a year but if
you squeal and they don't then you get
nothing
so again regardless of what the other
person does it's better for you to
defect to squeal of course the same is
true for person b in the scenario no
matter what person a does it's better to
defect so
both
will defect
but notice that's the worst possible
overall result
if they both defected collectively they
will serve eight years if only one
defected there would only be six years
served total and if they both just
cooperated they'd only get two
collectively stunningly guilt and
innocence do not matter in the context
of this game the payoffs are the same
whether or not the players are guilty so
both players still have a dominant
strategy to confess
and that's not only true in games legal
history is full of examples of people
confessing to crimes they didn't commit
because confessing would guarantee them
a lighter sentence
we can see this going back at least as
far as the salem witch trials in the
1690s
19 people most of them women were hanged
and one more was crushed by stones
but these weren't the only salem
residents accused of witchcraft
they were the ones who didn't confess to
witchcraft once they had been accused
according to the economist news magazine
quote perversely pleading innocent
tended to bring a death sentence whereas
those who confessed were spared some who
pleaded guilty to survive felt awful
remorse for lying end quote today we
know they must have been lying so you
can understand why they'd feel remorse
but i hope you can also understand why
they confess given the incentives they
faced were so similar to those from the
prisoner's dilemma game
this prisoner's dilemma was proposed by
merrill flood and melvin drescher in
1950. if you play it once well we've
analyzed that each decide each decides
to confess and if they both confess they
each get two years
but if you replay it repeatedly that
gets really interesting
and one of the reasons it's interesting
is that it becomes a model for
interaction between organisms
you can think of confessing as
cooperating maybe helping other
organisms gather food and you can think
of denying as competing hoarding your
food and not sharing it
now two organisms working together
that's best and two organisms each
working separately that's usually not as
good you know
if i help you gather food then you hoard
it i lose badly
this is sometimes called an iterated
prisoner's dilemma if we play this again
and again and again
you can see why decision researchers
might like this game it's simple elegant
and it measures something interesting
and relevant and you can very easily
change it in all kinds of ways to test
slightly different things
do the people know each other before the
game
do they know they'll have to interact
after the game
does the gender of each participant
matter
what about people from different
cultures or ages or backgrounds
the bbc even created a game show based
on the prisoner's dilemma called golden
balls in which players each had to
decide individually and in secret
whether to split a pot of money or try
to steal it from the other player
this game show built around this single
solitary decision cooperate or defect
produced surprising amounts of drama
when psychologists and behavioral
economists use the prisoner's dilemma
they usually don't use the story of the
two thieves instead like the game show
they set it up as a cooperation game
that involves cash payouts
the game for both groups involved
payouts that met the prisoner's dilemma
criteria that is
if both players cooperated that would
result in the highest group payout
if one player cooperated and the other
defected the defecting player would get
the highest possible payout and the
attempted cooperator would get the
lowest possible payout
and if both players decided to defect
that would result in the lowest group
payout
given a detailed explanation of the game
and exactly what the payoffs would be in
each situation people were faced with a
simple choice do i cooperate or do i
defect
if you trust your partner the smart move
is to cooperate if you doubt your
partner the smart move is to defect
in this experiment the only difference
between these two groups was what the
game was called
for half of the participants it was
called the community game
for the other half it was called the
wall street game
i'm sure you can already see where this
is going
when it was called the community game 67
percent of participants ended up
choosing to cooperate
when it was called the wall street game
the percentage of participants choosing
to cooperate dropped all the way down to
33 percent
doing nothing more than changing the
name of the game
was enough to reduce the likelihood of
cooperating from two-thirds to one-third
now
because we're doing this iteratively
there are many
complicated strategies that are possible
i could cooperate every time every other
time
my next move next time could depend on
yours this time you could ask what's a
good strategy here
and in 1984 robert axelrod wrote about a
tournament where computer programs were
asked to code strategies and we had and
they had those strategies compete
against each other some of these
computer programmers came up with
incredibly complicated strategies
interestingly these greedy strategies
where there's a lot of confessing
competing they didn't do very well
the winning strategy was also the
simplest strategy and it's called tit
for tat it beat all of the others
it goes like this in the first game you
cooperate you confess and then the next
game you do what the op what your
opponent did the last time
if you chose to cooperate you cooperate
too
you're nice i can be nice too if you
chose to compete
you compete too you're greedy i can be
greedy too
they went head to head they competed
against different algorithms and this
strategy tit for tat beat all of the
other algorithms
axelrod wrote this up in the book called
evolution of cooperation
this answered an age-old question if
organisms are and maybe even
corporations if they're greedy and they
want to survive and profit
why do they ever cooperate and the
answer here is that greed is sometimes
not the best long-term strategy
in cases where these organisms interact
repeatedly repeatedly it might not be in
their best interest to be greedy it
might be better in their better
long-term interest to cooperate it's a
simple strategy but it's incredibly
effective at establishing and then
maintaining cooperation in a repeated
prisoner's dilemma
that's why the allied generals hated it
the allies had more soldiers so from the
standpoint of allied high command a
battle where 10 000 died on each side
was a victory
from the general standpoint the
equilibrium outcome from the one-time
game was a good outcome
if you were a general back at
headquarters
how would you break out of the
cooperative tit-for-tat equilibrium
perhaps you could rotate troops
frequently
the problem is that troops talk to one
another as they're being rotated the old
guard tells the new guard the germans
aren't so bad you don't shoot them they
won't shoot you
or perhaps you could ask soldiers to
bring back battlefield souvenirs like
german barbed wire proving they'd gotten
out of their trenches and attacked the
germans
the problem this time is that allied
soldiers managed to find entire rolls of
german barbed wire making it easy for
them to send back a few feet at a time
what the generals finally settled on
were corpses they knew that if the
allied soldiers really raided the german
trenches there would be corpses either
allied corpses or german corpses and the
generals insisted on seeing them
it was these small but relentless allied
raids followed by the retaliation you'd
expect from germans playing tit for tat
that caused cooperation to break down
and fighting to resume
this of course is heartbreaking but it
shows how powerfully effective a simple
strategy like tit for tat can be
always begin by cooperating stand up for
yourself when people cheat you but be
quick to forgive if they go back to
cooperating and finally to quote axelrod
don't be too clever
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode the full list of series
that these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch all the
full series now on onedream.com and
don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel turn on notifications
and you'll get an alert every time we
post a new episode of perspectives